the lungs are where the body draws in
vital oxygen and exchanges it for carbon
dioxide but every breath we take is
accompanied by potentially harmful
microbes as well as particulates which
can damage delicate lung tissue to
counter these threats the lungs are
enriched in immune cells that repulse
invaders and repair injury but this
potent Arsenal comes at a heavy cost
over reactions or inappropriate
responses resulting diseases such as
asthma the lungs are spongy organs
composed of increasingly finer tubules
first comes the truck here and the
bronchi these are then divided into the
bronchioles which are wrapped in a
muscular sheath at the ends of the
bronchioles a microscopic air filled
sacs called alveoli in the case of
asthma most of the harmful immunological
events occur within the bronchi and
bronchioles the bronchial wall is made
up of an epithelium covered in tiny
hairlike structures called cilia and
interstitial and muscle cells goblet
cells scattered along the epithelium
discharge a thin layer of mucus into the
bronchial lumen the mucus is continually
swept back up through the lungs by the
action of the cilia this system is known
as the mucus escalator and is important
for removing inhaled particles trapped
within the mucus embedded throughout the
bronchial wall our immune cells such as
dendritic cells which sample antigens
from the lumen mast cells which are
packed with granules tiny packages rich
in histamine and innate lymphoid cells
or ILCs individuals with asthma need to
have been previously sensitized to a
specific environmental antigen the most
common is found in the feces of house
dust mites but symptoms can also be
worsened by respiratory virus infections
smoke or pollutants
when inhaled antigens contact the
epithelium they trigger the release of
two chemicals il 25 and TS LP which
simulate nearby dendritic cells and
innate lymphoid cells those il seeds the
dendritic cells leave the epithelium for
the lymph nodes where they activate T
cells and initiate an adaptive immune
response antigen can also pass through
the epithelium especially in conjunction
with damaging particles such as those
found within tobacco smoke or diesel
fumes some of this antigen can reach the
mast cells housed in smooth muscle
tissue the mast cells of asthmatic
individuals are unusual they have more
of an immune molecule called IgE stuck
to their surface the attached I GE then
binds the relevant antigen in this case
from house dust mites in a highly
specific manner when an antigen gets
bound to two IgE molecules it signals
the mast cell to D granulate and spill
out the contents of the granules the
granules innards then exert their
effects on surrounding cells and tissues
in asthma the granule contents cause
smooth muscle contraction and mucosal
edema leading to narrowing of the
bronchioles many anti-allergy drugs
target this key process of degranulation
back to those T cells in the lymph nodes
once activated T cells enter the
interstitial and team up with ILCs to
escalate the asthmatic response they
secrete chemical signals that recruit
other immune cells most critical of
these being eosinophils these cells play
central roles in almost all allergic
diseases
eosinophils squeeze through the
epithelium into the lumen and begin
releasing their own inflammatory signals
including il-5 il-13 and platelet
activating factor together these act on
goblet cells causing them to ramp up
production of mucus in a process known
as goblet hyperplasia by now the victim
is in the midst of an asthma attack as
the attack proceeds more and more
eosinophils are recruited into the lumen
and a mucus layer progressively thickens
the collective effects of smooth muscle
contraction and mucus overproduction
restrict air flow and result in the
classic symptoms of asthma including
difficulty breathing coughing and
wheezing multiple attacks can over time
lead to fibrosis and permanent injury of
the lung